professionals did everything they could
but once you reach past that tipping
point it gets too late
and all you can do is watch this virus
burn itself out
at the cost of thousands of lives
los angeles is on a very dangerous path
and if we don't make changes soon to our
day-to-day lives
we'll have more infections more
suffering more hospitalizations
and yes more death so i'm here before
you to share what our public health
professionals
our political leaders and our community
leaders are saying
so that we can take those simple acts
and those strong acts and do them right
now with the same
depth and determination that we showed
this spring and
save our city public health officials at
every level
have been making decisions and providing
guidance i know how tough it is for our
board of supervisors
that last week asked for a series of
triggers if numbers got
too high of things where we could trim
the sails trim the hours and yes if
necessary
have people stay at home i know those
are tough decisions
and i want our public health
professionals and our supervisors to
know
i support the decisions that you'll make
i support also our governor's decision
and the state mandate right now
that between 10 at night and five in the
morning that except for essential work
or essential trips that we stay at home
there's too much transition sorry too
much transmission
happening here right now in this county
too much transmission with too many
meetings of too many people
so the solution is simple we know it and
we can do it
stay away from each other assume
everybody you would see is infectious
and please let us not make this
thanksgiving
the deadliest day of this pandemic
i know how painful it is i know i'll be
facetiming
my mother and father who i've seen for
thanksgiving virtually every
year of my life but i want to spend
thanksgiving with them next year
we often think of love as often being
with someone who we love
we know this year love is not being
with someone that you love to stay with
that household
not to have two or three in the backyard
try doing everything you can
to help us collectively bring down the
rate of transmission
and to our businesses that are affected
i've said from the beginning we will
never
stop working to try to mitigate the loss
and the suffering of you and your
workers and i'll be saying a little bit
more about that in a moment
when we've hesitated in the past let me
be clear we arrive at these measures
later instead of sooner in other words
the economic suffering goes on for
months
instead of potentially weeks and the
damage done
in lives lost can never be repaired
whether you own a restaurant or work in
one
or you've been supporting the industry
by dining out or ordering
in more safely i know there are a lot of
worries out there
i've spoken with our city council
president i've spoken with our county
supervisors
know that if those orders do come down
where we have to
stop outdoor dining or limit the hours
of
other businesses we will take the funds
that we have
in business assistance and surge them
into those industries
to get us through this period to keep
those businesses alive to protect those
jobs
and to make sure that they can stand up
again
we could keep everything open and
eventually they will close anyway
over a longer period of time because the
numbers would be even more devastating
and i think that everybody who's asking
questions those are good and fair
questions ones that i share and the
plain truth
is there aren't a lot of satisfying
answers out there when people always say
where exactly is this coming from it's
coming from gatherings
it's coming from public places we meet
and it's coming from the weather
this clearly is one of those seasonal
viruses like the common cold
or the flu that surges at certain times
of the year
and we have to accept that that is not
just a reflection of things we're not
doing
it's just the reflection of the month
and the months we're living through
and that we have to accommodate that
adjust to that in order to save lives
the county has made it clear that
flattening the curve right now
it's the only way to get to reopening
businesses
to restoring our economy maybe the good
news of the vaccines has inspired us to
let down our guards a little bit more
but it's still some months before we can
distribute 20 million
doses of that vaccine to 10
million residents of la county the
responsibility of stopping the surge
rests in our hands
today first stay at home as much as
possible
second don't share your air and
third change your thanksgiving plans if
that hasn't been crystal clear enough
and i know it's tough but it's not that
tough let's just
not see other households don't travel
across town because it seems like a
short trip
and all you've heard is you can't travel
nationally or regionally
don't travel at all there's nothing
abstract about that
i think we all can feel kovit creeping
in
i know more people who know more people
or whose partners and
children are quarantined or have come up
positive
i know all of you out there maybe a few
of you are lucky enough not to but we
all see and feel those new cases we see
it in our testing centers where
yesterday 29 400 people came to city
testing centers a new record
as a side note our testing will be
closed on thursday
and friday but back open on saturday
because of thanksgiving and i want to
thank
all those volunteers from core 500
people who are helping every single day
to make sure that we can get that
testing done
if you'd like to volunteer with them
step up and help them
please visit their website which i'll
give you in one second
and by the way please donate to core as
well if you can
it's coreresponse.org coreresponse.org
and along with our firefighters and so
many people from the county our medical
personnel
do get tested and go to
coronavirus.lacity.org
testing or call 311.
and we have the capacity to continue
expanding testing to meet the need
we know that this is rare in america
right now
to continue to have a quick turnaround
time and to make sure that people can
get tested
within days whenever they need it so
take advantage of that but
a test is not a passport to party a test
is not an excuse
to go to somebody else's house for
thanksgiving a test
is to make sure you know if you're
positive so that you can isolate
and remember the rules i know it's
confusing if you're positive
you need to isolate for at least 10 days
from your first symptoms
and if you've been exposed to somebody
who's positive you need to quarantine
for 14
days i know it can seem like a long time
but it's the way that we can stop this
our transmission rate is now 1.18
meaning everybody infected is now
infecting 1.18 people
on average that might seem like a small
number but that is an exponential
increase from where we are we were and
that will result in us continuing to see
cases potentially double every couple
weeks
can you imagine if we're past 10 000
cases in just a couple weeks
can you imagine what it will mean to see
our hospital
hallways filled the way we saw in new
york or northern italy
let's make sure los angeles never gets
there through the work that we've done
together
i also want to announce about travel and
i hope you all know
that if for some reason you must travel
because of essential work or an
emergency
the state of california is recommending
a 14-day self-quarantine for anyone
landing at our airports
and tonight i'm announcing an additional
step for anybody flying
into los angeles that so they are fully
informed and educated about
our recommended quarantine so beginning
wednesday all passengers at the two
airports most busy airports we control
lax and van nuys
or at union station will be required to
fill out a brief online form
acknowledging the state policy
that recommends quarantine and visitors
arriving at lax or van nuys will be
informed of this new requirement
through signs hosted throughout the
airport and airlines are being asked to
notify
their passengers it'll take less than a
minute but you can see this form at
travel.lacity.org
and it'll be available starting this
evening but again if there's any way for
you to avoid travel
cancel those plans emergencies and
essential work travel
should be the only excuse why we get on
a plane anywhere
right now you see everything that we're
doing right now is focused on a singular
goal
to save lives to make sure that our
economy
springs back to be certain that
when the holidays roll around that we're
not looking at a christmas
with people dying in our hospitals and
no beds available but maybe a place
where yes
with our families in our household
exchanging presence that we bought at
local businesses
because we responded to this right now
at this critical
juncture for addition to the new rules
on outdoor dining that seemed
like they are coming online wednesday
from the county i wanted to reiterate
other key updates from the county and
the state for businesses that are
operating
indoors you are now limited to 25
capacity
at personal care establishments such as
salons and tattoo parlors
everyone is required to wear a mask and
services are by appointment only
no food no drinks the state of
california as i said earlier has
implemented a curfew or at least
only essential travel from 10
to 5 a.m for all cities in the most
restrictive covet 19 tier and we are in
that tier
and that curfew is in effect until at
least december 21st
meant to slow the spread of the virus by
restricting parties and late night
activities events that are accelerating
the spread
statewide so in los angeles that means
all of us should stay inside our homes
between
10 p.m and 5 a.m with the exception of
essential activities
buying grocery visiting doctors if you
work in those hours
or other healthcare providers or
essential services like pharmacies
and if everyone abides by these rules if
everyone takes these seriously
these small but critical sacrifices we
will get through this
we're not asking you to take up arms and
to go overseas to fight a war
we're not looking at some of the
sacrifices that have been made by
generations before us
we're just asking for you to stay home
we're asking for you not to be with
others
it seems like the smallest of asks but
that smallest of asks
can defeat this smallest of risks these
this virus that we cannot see but that
we feel this virus that has caused so
much devastation to us and to our
families
we can change the tide
so i shared with you the numbers from
today
the 6124 record cases
l.a county is projected to reach half a
million
total cases by year's end and the one
sorry the 11 511 people whose lives
depend
on you tonight you know
the folks that have loved ones in the
hospital i just want to address
and those who were part of the eight
families who lost someone today
and we know those numbers are going to
surge it goes cases
and then hospitalizations which are
seeing surge and within a week or two
we'll see the death surge as well for
anybody hanging on
and praying that god will spare their
loved ones and that are
suffering in a hospital know that we see
you
and we feel you and for everybody out
there who's lucky enough
lucky enough not to be one of those
families i want you to think about the
person you love most in the world
who's sitting next to you or maybe who
you haven't seen
a parent a loved one a co-worker
and know that they are the one whose
life you're saving
or maybe even as powerfully it's your
own life
that you wouldn't be around for them if
we don't do these simple things
to be able to save lives and to stop the
spread
it's not too late to get the train back
on the tracks
i don't believe this is all because of
the bad behavior we've done it's
partially just the season
but whatever the cause a combination of
letting our guard down
of not having a season
that is conducive to stopping the spread
we know what we must do this is serious
and the choice is ours
and i trust you i care about you and i
will always do everything i can
to protect you and this incredible city
filled with angels if we
see more than 4 500 cases a day over a
five-day period
which the county estimates that we're
basically at
or if hospitalizations exceed more than
2 000 a day
we'll begin to need implementing further
measures
or maybe right there on that bubble
maybe there but all the data is trending
in the wrong direction
so let's do everything that we can let's
keep getting tested
and let's keep staying home let's keep
keeping our distance and don't share
your air
and let's cancel those trips and step up
and volunteer at coreresponse.org or
donate there
get yourself indoors
and get some place safe and make sure
that this is the moment when we say we
met the challenge
and we turn the tide this year has given
us a whole new vocabulary to communicate
to the people around us
who we care about wearing a mask
that says i'll keep you safe
keeping your distance says i'm here for
you
acting to protect our most vulnerable
neighbors we demonstrate what it means
to be a city that takes care of its own
and much of our ability to take care of
ourselves depends on not just the person
next to us
and the person we work with but people
whose names we will never
know and people who are not part of our
households collectively doing the right
thing
if we continue down this road a lot of
people will get sick
but if we take the fork that we have
taken twice this year
and do everything right and take this
moment to be serious about this pause
and this change we will see things
get better so i'm asking you to keep
making those sacrifices and keep feeling
strong about your role
and to look back just as i said and to
see your fellow angelenos years from now
walking these beautiful streets because
of what you
did so let's continue to do our part to
stay healthy and to stay
safe and to stay at home strength and
love los angeles
let's rise to this moment thank you
as usual i will take uh questions and
then i'll speak in spanish as well
i'll take the first question thank you
thank you and our first question comes
from joel [ __ ]
from breitbart news please go ahead
good evening hi uh good evening i have
and happy thanksgiving by the way i have
two questions sure
the first is about the coronavirus
which you've been talking about
california is part of a group of states
on the west coast
that is going to test a vaccine
independently do you think that's going
to slow
the delivery of
vaccines to angelino's and the second
question is about
the 300 homicide mark that was reached
over the weekend you announced cuts to
the police 150 million
in june and the homicide division has
had to cut back among others
do you think that is an outcome of the
decision to cut funding to the police
sure on the first one i certainly hope
that it not only doesn't slow it but it
accelerates
testing a vaccine independently and
being able with incredible
medical professionals we have from
washington state all the way down to
california
that being able to validate that
reassure people and to help distribute
that will be something that will
accelerate
states including ours be able to have a
vaccine and have it more quickly
a second no in cities that have not cut
the police department we actually see
higher numbers of homicides in many of
them
we have made cuts in all of our
departments in the police department it
is a proportionate amount that is shared
by
other departments as well in fact it's a
little bit lower as a percentage
and we've seen an average around the
country of homicides up during this
even though crime overall is down during
this pandemic up
by more than 30 percent here it's a
little bit under that average but that's
no saving grace to know that homicides
are only up
26 um we'll have over as we announced
today over 300 homicides for the first
time
in more than a decade and while crime is
still at record lows
we're seeing more guns across this
country more ammunition
more shootings and more frustration in
fact worldwide there's trends when i
talk with my fellow mayors around
the world especially where there's easy
access to guns
of more violence being perpetrated in
the midst of the pandemic so there's
something about this
but you can go straight to cities that
have even increased their police budgets
that have had
higher increases so i don't believe at
all there's any causality there
second we're going to continue making
sure that we don't just look at this as
an issue of policing
our police do incredible work i've never
shied away from this
podium of lifting up the heroes that are
lapd police officers
and i believe that in my bones folks who
solve crimes people who go out there
in fact our metropolitan division is
working doing crime solving around
homicides in a way that they were in a
year ago
supplementing that our officers have
taken more guns off the street in the
last two months
than i think any two months previous so
there's amazing work happening
but we know that it's not just an issue
for police when i've talked to experts
and we
had my cabinet this uh today talk about
this issue um
one of the things that was crystal clear
from our chief of police as well as
folks who are interventionists
is that there's just not enough people
with other things to do the programs we
would have like at the park after dark
the gang reduction and youth development
programs are not there and the jobs
are not there in a pandemic so we are
going to surge and are already starting
to surge resources there
dozens of more ambassadors safety
ambassadors
these are sometimes former gang members
or people with lived experience
who we've shown through studies through
ucla can reduce crime by 40 percent more
than just police officers alone
when you bring policing and intervention
programs to our streets
these are the peacemakers who know the
personalities the ones who can step
in front of the guns and stop the
killings and so we are surging dozens
more
they are recently hired they're being
trained up and they're being deployed
and i do believe that that will help us
bring some of this increase
down um and it's absolutely critical
last thing i'll say
is one murder is too much and one death
from covet 19 is too much
we've seen an increase of you know 40 or
50 deaths
probably projected by the end of the
year in terms of the homicide rate
when you look at covid and 11 511 deaths
i hope we'll keep both of those in our
minds and do everything we can
and if folks would like to help on the
homicide side we still
are offering youth jobs remotely
especially in communities where we know
that's a proven strategy
so if you're interested in your business
hiring
a young person to do remote or critical
in-person work please go to higherla
youth.org
and be a part of that movement thanks so
much for both questions
next question and that comes from dakota
smith from the la times
please go ahead hello dakota good
evening mayor happy thanksgiving
um you know there's a lot of talk about
your political future
and there's a lot of political
consultants who hope there's a mayor's
race next year so
they can have work and i know you
previously said it's more likely than
not that you'll be here in 2022 as mayor
but today is there anything more
definitive that you can say on that
topic is there anything you can say to
the people of los angeles about
whether you'll be here in 2022 with
mayor thank you so much
thank you dakota no i don't have
anything to add i'll i'll be honest with
you i have been
focused 110 on these numbers and on
covid and on saving lives it's
one of the last things on my mind right
now um you know we have
deaths that are going to be increasing
we have record numbers of cases and so
i don't have anything to add on that not
because i have anything to
hide i just have nothing to add my job
right now my job number one
is to make sure i protect the lives of
angelinos and everything else
recedes in comparison thank you dakota
next next question thank you and that
comes from
ron lim from the la times please go
ahead hey ron how are you
hey good thanks so much mr mayor for
taking our questions i have three
related questions for you
uh do you support further measures to
implement a targeted safer at home
order that will be talked about at
tomorrow's county board of supervisors
meeting
um the second is what do you think of
supervisor barger's opposition's
prohibiting outdoor restaurant dining
and another
safer at home measure she argues it's
unfair and that case counts aren't
coming from reopened businesses but from
large gatherings
but experts tell me it's all the above
and the last question is do you have
confidence that the board of supervisors
will make the right decision to protect
public health and if you don't think
that they
don't make the right decision in the end
what would you do thanks so much mr
mayor
thank you um yes i do support them um
i do think that if we don't take this i
know this is not popular with everybody
but if we don't take these sorts of
actions now
when will we now we're smarter than
we've ever been about covid
so there are nuances to that we learned
with certain industries
places to keep business going and to
keep people safe
construction sites uh other places where
we haven't seen
that kind of spread and if i understand
the county data right it's anywhere from
about 10 or 15 percent
may come from outdoor dining that's not
an insignificant number
even if the theory that i've also read
from some county data but i haven't
seen it in a kind of granular level that
as much as 50
is coming from people gathering with
each other in more private spaces
we have to do everything we can right
now and
it's a business argument as much as it
is a human life argument
human lives first and foremost to
protect those to
punch this down over a series of a few
weeks
which is my deep hope and at the same
time to surge resources
to keep payrolls and to keep um
businesses going
i know those are tough things to do and
tough things to say but i'm not here
to dance around this issue or to take
you know half measures
and watch people die i don't think these
numbers lie
i don't think that we can sit around and
say let's put this off a couple more
weeks
so i do support it second your last
question i do think they will make the
right decision i've talked
to a couple of those supervisors today i
know there will be some push and pull
there may be some trimming of the
policies there may be
a day or two added here or there but i
think their policies that they adopted
are clear
hit these thresholds and these things
happen i do hope we all collectively
whether it's a city
a county or the state always gives some
time to prepare
because i know how difficult it's been
during the year when suddenly 24 hours
from now or that moment
suddenly the rules change so it's good
that we've had the
notice and i hope that there will be
some notice for as we've seen in europe
you know if it's a stay-at-home order
this is happening on this certain day
not
this hour that helps people be able to
adjust it helps government to be able to
take the money that we have it might not
be enough but we will surge it to those
businesses surge it to those employees
surge it to making sure that things like
those restaurants have a shot at
surviving
but the business argument is very clear
too don't do these things
and what are we going to do wait till
gets to 10 15
20 000 cases and then suddenly say we're
shutting down
and now we're shut down for two or three
months i think that that is
irresponsible for our businesses
as painful as it is for them to hear
this news so
um yes and by the way if if for any
reason
you know those measures weren't taken of
course and i've talked to fellow mayors
like robert garcia who today announced
hospitalizations in long beach
are up 250 percent in the last two weeks
we have the option to be more
restrictive inside cities
it gets very confusing people always
come and some might even protest in my
house saying you've closed things down
i actually don't close things down it's
usually the state or the county
but if there isn't action taken we do
have that option of being more
restrictive but not less
so uh but i've i have confidence in the
board of supervisors and i know they are
struggling with how to do it
but they will do the right thing as they
have all year long
thanks ron thank you again 1-0 if you'd
like to ask a question
and now to the line of john rigardi from
the los angeles magazine
hey john hi how are you good after good
afternoon mayor and happy thanksgiving
um
previously when uh there have been
threats of a surge in the health care
system being overwhelmed uh you have
worked with others to
take additional steps um are you you
know what are you doing this time is
there any possibility of
the convention center being put into
place as a field hospital or anything
akin to the
early consideration when uh the naval
ship mercy was
directed up to los angeles yes and thank
you for the question john
um whether it's the uh hospital system
and
hospitals that we've had closed in the
past that we looked at reopening
or whether it's using the convention
center as a field hospital we've kept
those contingency plans alive
i had to make a decision about four
months ago whether we permanently closed
that down or kept it kind of on life
support
and we've kept it on life support so
that absolutely is an option we'll
consult with the department of health
services
in the county which really prepares for
the hospital capacity
and look while it's still some ways off
the way this is accelerating is it
doesn't feel like it's that far off and
county projections now do say
if this rate of acceleration that we've
seen last week in the last three weeks
continues
i want to reiterate we could be out of
hospital beds by christmas time
but at that point we can add more
hospital beds and the hospitals
themselves
are preparing they can also adjust beds
adjust more to be for covert 19 patients
and places like our convention center
could be for non-coveted
patients or those recovering and no
longer infectious so we absolutely can
surge that
field hospital up again if necessary and
we'll we'll follow the county's lead
i think i don't see the the mercy
necessarily coming back though
it's something we could certainly ask
the federal government for that what was
more useful than the ship itself or the
teams that we had
so we might reach out to our military
counterparts to have more teams to surge
into
places that we're seeing hot spots as
well thanks john
great thank you mayor you bet next
question please
thank you and that comes from the line
of elisa ross from telemundo please go
ahead
hola we want to start this hello mayor
garcetti and happy thanksgiving to you
and your family
thank you i was hoping to get an answer
in spanish now tomorrow
your office along with some partners is
opening a super site in san fernando
and i understand that supersite is going
to have a walk-up component as opposed
to the drive-through
testing site that we've seen so far what
is the need for these
uh super sites especially with this
walk-up component
in hispanic areas for folks that may not
have transportation
can you tell me a little bit about that
in spanish and also i understand that at
some point
you will be able to dispense that theme
from that site can you talk to me about
that
yeah we could dispense i'm sorry i
missed the last dispense the what the
fee
i understand that at some point vaccines
will also vaccines yes
absolutely so all of our sites we're
looking okay
let me i'll say very briefly in english
and then i'll give you an answer in
spanish as well
so yes we do have nine of the ten
neighborhoods with the biggest surge
have been in the northeast san fernando
valley
so we are absolutely going to
need not only to have more of a site and
some people said why we had it there
before we have hansen dam
there's there's coverage but we need
additional coverage so we're going to
make this a mega site and we did need a
place
where folks who didn't have
transportation could walk up uh who
couldn't come through a car
we've noticed that a number of
communities something i shared also with
joe biden and kamala harris today was
that disproportionate impact
52 percent of our cases right now are
latino
so we will absolutely uh be making that
available primarily as a walk-up site
obviously people can drive close by
and walk up to it but it'll allow a
dense neighborhood
that's transit accessible for people to
be able to walk up
and to take that that could be a site
where we dispense vaccines right now the
county and we're at the table with them
is looking at a plan that would really
be through our primary health providers
but i want to make sure people who don't
have health insurance
and don't have a place they regularly go
are not
left behind so most of us would go to
our doctors go to
our hospitals go to kaiser or whatever
system we're a part of
just as we do with flu vaccines even our
pharmacies and get that paid for by our
insurance
but we're going to supplement that and
that absolutely could be a site
in san fernando is important
uh
um
all right i think that was the last
question in english or spanish so i will
now
turn to spanish thank you all and thank
you all for taking the actions of saving
lives
um with that let me turn to spanish
los angeles
[Music]
[Music]
a
or a union station
in la pahina
los angeles
los angeles
por
los angeles thank you we'll see you soon
[Music]
thing about it is you need to know how
to do it correct